foreign
Josiah is with us in New Hampshire hey
Josiah what's up
hey Ken and uh Dave how are you both
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
glad to hear it I'm 25 years old married
and um debt free and baby step four and
applying for term life insurance so I'm
going through Xander and got approved
for 500 000 but I'm wondering whether I
should go with a 20 or a 30-year term my
thought being if we're debt free now in
20 years I'll be 45 will I have a net
worth high enough to not require that
insurance or should I go to 30 and stay
insured until 55 at which place I can be
more confident that would be that we'd
be there how's your health
health is good
um you smoke no uh nope non-smoker are
you obese
nope okay uh I would buy a 20-year
okay now let me tell you how I did that
okay
here's what actually happened with me
knock on wood I've been healthy as a
horse my whole life okay hardly seen the
inside of a hospital as I was visiting
someone else
so um
what happened was I bought my first term
life insurance when I was your age
and uh I bought a 15-year level but then
what happened was we added kids we added
income
and I wanted to upgrade the insurance
and so I had a choice then of buying yet
a new policy and getting rid of the old
one or just buying additional so like
about 500 000 in your case okay later on
about I might buy another 500 000 but
that might be three years from now or
five years from now and as you've
noticed it's not very expensive
mm-hmm it doesn't cost much money and so
what's going to end up happening is
you're unless you lose your health along
the way your ability to get insurance
you're going to end up adding policies
or buying whole new policies and
starting the clock over
gotcha so you don't need a 30 you're
going to end up buying a series of
policies or replacing the earlier
policies as you want more and more and
more depending on which way the math
works the best and
um then you're going to be in a position
to uh
begin dropping them later or when you
look up in your 45 and you go we're 100
self-insured you just cut the cord on
the whole thing and let them let them
float away
um and so but what ended up happening in
our case was I've added policies uh
every five years or so from 25 all the
way up to 60 not 60 about 50 something
and I kept some policies even though I
didn't need them recently just swi
Sharon wants them
and it really didn't have anything to do
I mean it wasn't like she's not she that
like that policy is going to make the
difference what she eats or not that's
kind of silly but even those policies
are starting to expire now and we're
definitely not going to buy them even if
she wants them I'm done with this so um
we have convinced her that she's okay I
think I've got a acronym for that one
what if Sharon wants it is swi you just
came up with a new One D DC Dave doesn't
care
DDC you're not doing it you're done well
I mean it's it's you know she's okay and
she knows she's okay now that's gotten
rid of the that name but what ends up
happening is you're not buying one
policy that's going to serve you
throughout your entire life you end up
adding incrementally as you go along and
so five years from now if you buy
another 20-year policy or another
15-year policy you just started that
clock over on that portion the other one
when it expires you're probably not
going to renew it you know 20 years from
now that's where I am at you're
describing our journey as we begin to
have kids three kids you added as you
went along yes added as I went along
obviously we were able to upgrade
in-house over time and so sitting with
our smart investor Pro we determine what
that right amount was and I it was like
three or four years ago I just did it
and so that'll probably be the last one
obviously I mean we shouldn't need it at
all so that you described exactly the
journey that that I'm in and I'm I'm 23
years older than him now but the way our
brains work and I did the same thing
Josiah when I was your age I'm thinking
well if I want to just get a 30 and I'm
done it's over but it really it's it's
more life that comes at you in layers
rather than linearly like that well
explain to Young Folks so if they're
getting ready to start a family what you
recommend when you go from a couple with
no kids to one kid or two how you the
whole time I'm just saying you know 10
to 12 times your income because when
you're 25 if he's getting 500 000 then
maybe he makes 50 Grand okay if
something happens to him you know
if she's got 500 000 bucks if she's got
one if she got a baby she's still got
500 000 bucks invest that at 10 in a
good mutual fund if it's making ten
percent it would pay off pay out fifty
thousand bucks we've replaced his income
without even touching the principal and
so that's the idea of 10 to 12 times
your income on on you and guys you got
to go to Xander insurance and get a
quote if you haven't done this because
the deal is people are blown away how
cheap term life insurance is and it's
gotten cheaper over the years oh yeah
right I mean I bought some one time at
45 and I came back in my 50s to buy more
and even though I was seven or eight
years older it was cheaper yeah because
the rates had come down because they're
using better and better and better
Actuarial tables that are more modern
and reflect reflect the uh the health
Improvement they were using tables from
the 1940s oh yeah and then they started
using tables from the 1960s and now
they're using tables because life
expectancy has changed yeah and I mean
it's already cheap but if you have the
preferred health designation I don't
know if that's what they call it you can
make a lot of money I like to recommend
this to dudes I dropped weight like a
wrestler three years ago when I did it
super discipline Dave yep and I got the
preferred rate and saved got more oh
here's another I'm still safe if you
smoke oh yeah it's double Oh yeah double
yeah double oh that's why I asked if he
smoked or he was obedient yeah that's
right because it's double all you gotta
do is just quit smoking and it cuts your
insurance in half oh and it saves you on
all the cigarettes oh and it saves you
on all the health problems yeah and yeah
and no Quarter Pounders within three
days of taking your blood test there's
some world-class advice Dave right here
on the Range that sounds like that came
from experience